mistakes lava more hate him if you're
learning a foreign language you're bound
to make them and when you make them
you're bound to hear about them that's
right I'm talking about feedback
some people hate getting feedback and
say that it's humiliating and
demotivating others love it claiming
that getting lots of feedback is the
only way to grow
but which is it really is feedback
helpful or hurtful in this video I'll
share my answer that could surprise you
oh and don't forget to watch until the
end because I got some powerful tips on
how to handle feedback like a pro when
talking about getting feedback in
language learning there are generally
two schools of thought either a feedback
hurts or feedback helps let's start with
the first idea that feedback hurts when
people say that feedback hurts they're
usually describing scenarios that
include taking a language test and
having your mistakes circled in red ink
or blanking in the middle of a
conversation because you suddenly forgot
a word or learning for years only to
travel abroad and find out that no one
can understand you conversely when
people say that feedback helps they
typically mention situations like taking
a language test and finding out that you
performed better than you did on your
last one talking to a native speaker and
realizing they can actually hold a
decent conversation realizing that no
matter how long you learn you'll always
be able to find ways to improve people
in the feedback herds category often
find that getting corrected is deeply
humiliating and something to be avoided
at all costs people in the feedback
helps category see getting corrected as
an inevitable But ultimately positive
part of the process that can help direct
your attention towards areas of
improvement but which of these camps is
right as a language learner should you
run for feedback or embrace it truth be
told I believe the answer is actually
somewhere in between you should avoid
Corrections in some situations and
actively seek them out in others but how
can we know when to do which how can we
determine when feedback is useful and
when it is useless
allow me to explain in all my years of
language learning I've gotten thousands
if not tens of thousands of Corrections
getting these Corrections has made me
feel great terrible and everything in
between all this experience has helped
me understand that the utility of
language feedback is dependent on three
key factors these factors include your
overall skill level and your target
language how you feel about feedback and
how the feedback is delivered let me
explain each of these factors in detail
so that you can learn to absorb only the
most useful forms of feedback and ignore
the rest let's talk about skill level it
goes without saying that there's not a
language Learner in this world who
speaks his or her target language
perfectly without making any mistakes
that being said everyone is liable to
receive feedback no matter if you're an
absolute beginner or the most advanced
near native on the planet
so who then is feedback most useful for
since beginners make lots of mistakes
and advanced speakers make less you
might assume that feedback is most
useful for beginners who need it most of
all but I actually believe the opposite
feedback is most useful for intermediate
and advanced speakers and least useful
for beginners why is this because when
you start learning a language from
scratch there's simply too many things
to pay attention to since you know very
little of the language feedback that
addresses all or even most of your
shortcomings would be absolutely
overwhelming like drinking from a
firehouse
as you progress towards the intermediate
level and Beyond you'll get to a point
where you do most things decently well
meaning there's actually a lot fewer
things you could be corrected on at
least compared to when you began at this
stage your brain is much better equipped
to handle the realities of receiving
feedback and using that feedback to
improve your skills since a certain
amount of the language has already
become automatic for you you have the
mental bandwidth to pay attention to
your weak points and actually fix them a
beginner to whom nearly everything is
brand new does not have this luxury so
giving feedback to a beginner is much
less likely to be useful
let me give you an example of this from
my own life recently I took a trip to
the Italian city of Siena with Max a
German friend of mine throughout the
trip we alternated between speaking
German and Italian so that we could both
practice our skills despite the fact
that German is one of my strongest
languages I asked maths to share every
single mistake that he noticed in my
speech it wasn't always easy to get
correct in this matter but I made sure
to take lots of notes why because I know
that my German is otherwise good enough
that I can spend my time and mental
energy focusing on these mistakes and
gradually eliminating them from a speech
let's move on to the next major factor
that determines whether or not
Corrections are useful your feelings
about feedback in many ways feedback is
an inescapable part of life even outside
of languages most of us have spent years
in school getting all different kinds of
feedback grades on exams academic report
cards and all sorts of reactions from
our friends families and even complete
strangers these experiences are often
uncomfortable or even downright negative
no one likes to fail an exam or told
that they're not quite as good at
something as they would like to be this
of course happens in language learning
as well when we make mistakes with our
language use we risk being judged
misunderstood or even laughed at and
that's not fun for anyone but it would
be unfair to paint feedback as a wholly
negative experience for example I'm sure
you've had many experiences in your life
where feedback helped you overcome a
stubborn obstacle or achieve something
that you previously thought impossible
so even though you've likely experienced
times where feedback was both welcome
and unwelcome you've likely developed a
habit of expecting one or the other type
in your mind you automatically assume
that correction will help you or that it
will hurt you regardless of the actual
situation over time these assumptions
become a general feeling you either like
getting corrected or you hate it they
make you feel great or make you feel
numb with little in between if you're in
the latter category where having someone
correct you makes you feel bad then most
feedback is not going to be of much use
to you even if the person correcting you
is well intentioned the reality of
having your performance scrutinized
might throw you off and impact your will
to keep learning on the other hand if
you're in the habit of seeing all or
most feedback as constructive and useful
then that's exactly what it will be in
this way your feelings about getting
corrected become a sort of
self-fulfilling prophecy you get the
exact amount of value from them that you
expect to all that being said I think
it's much better to have an open mind
towards feedback rather than a close one
but how can you cultivate such an open
perspective if you do not have it right
now that's a topic for a different video
but here are my tips again accept that
all language Learners make mistakes even
the most skilled of us challenge
yourself to remain positive and upbeat
even as you make mistakes and get
corrected for it if you're able to
quickly recover after a misstep you'll
find that people often forget you made
the mistake at all and finally realize
that Corrections are often the clearest
Pathway to improve after all if you
don't know what you're doing wrong
you'll never be able to fix it
now let's move on to the last factor
that influences the quality of feedback
how feedback is delivered let's imagine
for a moment that you're learning
Russian you're chatting with a Russian
speaker for the first time and in the
middle of the conversation you say the
Russian equivalent of I want to go
school
almost instantly the person you were
speaking to interrupts you to point out
that you said something wrong almost as
if it didn't matter what you were trying
to communicate but only the way in which
you communicated it you get the
impression that this person only wants
to speak with foreigners who get their
language right and that's it
now let's rewind back to the moment you
made your mistake and try to picture a
different situation unfolding the
Russian speaker listens attentively and
happily until you're done speaking and
then says something to the effect of I'm
currently going to school too oh and by
the way you made a little mistake there
it should be I want to go to school
rather than I want to go school it's not
a big deal though you're doing great
which of these situations sounds more
pleasant to you the latter of course
even though you received a correction in
both situations the positive delivery of
the feedback in the second scenario made
the whole experience more useful to you
as a learner in the earlier scenario the
Russian speaker was rude and impatient
even though a mistake like I want to go
school is perfectly understandable in
Russian this individual was more worried
about catching your mistake than
actually participating in the
conversation and that's why my final
factor of feedback quality is about
delivery well-delivered feedback is
almost always useful while poorly
delivered feedback should always be
ignored even if the correction is
essentially the same if someone is being
too harsh too nitpicky or even too
enthusiastic about pointing out your
mistakes they're forgetting an essential
fact the language is about communication
and meaning can often be communicated
effectively even in the presence of
mistakes
native speakers are capable of
understanding quite a bit without
judging every little aspect of your
language use and that brings me to my
last point the most useful feedback of
all is the feedback that you ask for if
someone is giving you lots of
unsolicited feedback or giving you
feedback at inopportune times then those
Corrections are much less helpful than
they otherwise would be if you want help
from other people on your language
skills be sure to ask for it and then
lay out clear guidelines for the kind of
help you are looking for the best
feedback is feedback that is positive
appropriate and well timed so make sure
to let the native speakers you interact
with know what kinds of Correction you
want and when you want them all right
that's it for our discussion of feedback
at least for now before we go let's
review what we talked about most people
feel either positively or negatively
about getting corrected when using their
target languages despite this we can't
really say that feedback is either good
or bad instead I happen to believe that
the quality of feedback is dependent on
number of factors that have to do with
both the learner and the person giving
the feedback these factors are your
skill level and your target language the
way you feel about feedback and how the
feedback is delivered in a nutshell my
advice is this if you're too new at your
target language or too anxious about
getting Corrections then most feedback
will be useless for you conversely if
you're more advanced and actually feel
like Corrections will help you then you
should get as much feedback as possible
but no matter which side you're on you
should not waste your time paying
attention to people who are too harsh or
too frequent with their Corrections
especially if you did not ask for them
it's just not worth it
that's all for now thanks for watching
and as always happy language learning